have have you seen what's going on with
seth rogen on twitter
yeah what's up with him he's been
yelling it's not it's not just like a
couple people he's like
spiraling so this was uh count dankula
uh kandacular made a video or whatever
and he made some jew joke
uh you know as he does and it was it was
video or something it was very actually
low-key it wasn't anything crazy like we
do worse stuff on this show in my
opinion
and seth seth rogen sent him a dm saying
are you
are you a jewish person and kentucky no
i'm not have you seen the video
then you're either someone who's not
funny has astoundingly bad judgment or
most likely both
i have you're not funny i work in the
sphere he's
he works in the sphere dude he's been
very angry lately
yeah and i don't know what his problem
is and here's the last here's the last
one
and if this breaks your country's laws
in regards to hate crime you're an even
bigger idiot is that a threat
that's a threat that's a threat right
that's a threat from the from the star
of knocked up
yeah he's which you know let's be honest
he probably
he i wouldn't say but he did just take
the condom off and knock her up
all right so you know and we can
interpret whatever you want i'm i'm with
you royce i'm going to back up what roy
said
seth rogen is in movies
in in movies and i mean in real life
allegedly
i didn't say that i know a legend i
didn't say that
i mean that's a true seth rogen
he's not a but he's a threat to the
community i didn't say well he might be
that he is not removed from the
community
i don't think he's sad i don't think
he's that at all and
and i'll i'll back royce up even further
i'll die on this hill no don't die in
anything the los angeles police
department is involved
covering up that's not true covering up
we're just joking
he's making jokes an endless list of
[ __ ] jokes by seth rollins
[Laughter]
no that one is true yeah and it's men
but it's it's the same thing this is
satire
we're all having fun we're just kidding
and obviously we're no way making any
sort of legally binding statement
about seth rogen uh are you jewish
because if you are unless you're jewish
you can't make jokes about your way to
ask if i'm
that's exactly what i meant it's a weird
way to ask if i'm a
so um
next time you want to ask me if i'm
jewish just ask hey do you
have money so find a more roundabout way
to ask me that question
so yeah he's been going around and he's
been doing this to different people like
he sure has
no no not the uh he hasn't
no i don't mean he's not you admit that
you're a thing he's not that
kidding it's obviously it was a joke it
was satire
and obviously we know i was messing
around legally speaking legally speaking
no
let me be clear here legally speaking no
i have no knowledge about seth rogen
forcibly doing anything to whatever
we'll call the lawyers later
no i don't want to call a lawyer please
if you see seth rogen
he may be armed no just please avoid him
at all costs
no it's obviously a joke we don't know
great now i'm going to get a southern
here and it's going to be asking me if
i'm jewish and
that's going to be weird you call me
[Laughter]
is that going to be the whole thing that
you pretty much announced that yeah
god i'd rather do a michael rappaport
again than [ __ ] seth rogen
[ __ ] off seth i'm in no mood today
um look obviously we're drunk just
answer maybe rso media that would have
been the best we're just joking seth
rogen listen if you're listening to this
this is just like one of your movies
except we're funny so
by the way how about [ __ ] uh hey
dankela instead of trying to be an edgy
boy and be
all cool how about next time do what i
do are you jewish
um yeah
and then they leave you alone and i'm
lying all the time i lie
all the time in these people oh really
are you yeah i'm jewish and these are
first-hand accounts of things that i
experienced in my family and i'm like oh
they don't people are late twitter
people are lazy they don't want to
actually research things
uh so he's been going around he's been
fighting with everybody he fights with
like ted cruz and stuff
what is he so angry about the fact that
he hasn't made a good movie in 15 years
mike i'd be mad too
i guess i would be mad too if i got my
if i got outshined by
jonah hill yeah sir you're right that's
probably what's bugging him
no you know what bugs even more than
that not only that i got shined by jonah
hill
but at least he always had way out with
johnny hill's fap but now jonah hill
skinny he doesn't even have that over
him
like seth rogen is fatter than jonah
hill now well jonah likes to
he he he likes to fluctuate he sure
likes to fluctuate doesn't he yeah
which is like way more unhealthy like
jonah hill's better off just being fat
but if you're gonna keep fluctuating
you're gonna die
yeah but there was another one where he
was yelling at somebody yeah how stupid
they were
and they were like okay like somebody
tweeted that
which was a funny tweet that i guess
apparently they'd been using dog shampoo
oh yeah i saw that one and they were
like i've just been using dog shampoo
and i didn't realize until now
and he was like are you stupid on
twitter and they were like
well i mean probably but you know i was
just having fun
like it was just you know showing
sharing a fun little joke yeah it's not
funny you're stupid like it was just
this weird thing where you're like
i don't think the person was trying to
be laugh out loud funny i think they
were just sharing an interesting
anecdote
about something they did yeah so so the
so this here here's the back
i found it so this is what it was uh so
it turns out i've been using dog shampoo
in my hair for at least a few months
i only discovered it when i ran out and
needed to get more uh this is
partly my own fault but it doesn't help
that amanda hammer who uh
oh amanda amanda armand hammer the
amanda hammer german hammer
amanda hammer amanda hammer the founder
of arm and hammer
has the word pets in like four point
typeface i'm guessing this is common
and then seth rogen just wrote you're
stupid
and then uh jonathan k says troll by
seth rogen achievement unlocked
seth rogen i'm not trolling you this is
objectively stupid i honestly have no
clue
who uh who you are beyond this stupid
tweet
jonathan k well you celebrities seem
like a happy people
for real though what did you expect the
reaction to be tons of people being like
yeah i also use dog shampoo by accident
who doesn't
no here's what dude this was just a joke
and not even wrong with him not even a
joke
a mildly amusing anecdote based on a
real thing
do you know what he expected this is
what he probably expected um
royce say that you've been accidentally
using dog shampoo i mean you know i
realized i've accidentally been using
dog shampoo and i just realized when i
ran out oh man that's hilarious
man you must smell like an idiot yeah i
felt pretty [ __ ] stupid ah that was a
mildly amusing anecdote you see that's
all that that's all you're expecting
when you do something like that
just a light chuckle and people go were
you really using dog [ __ ]
oh that's funny hey we all do weird
things sometimes and i'm not even
saying the original anecdotes that funny
it's just mildly amusing it's just a
thing that you go ah that's kind of
funny i guess so this is just a dude who
i mean look seems like
this jonathan k guy is followed by
jordan peterson
followed by dinesh d'souza and two other
people so he this guy
seems like he's probably some sort of
right-wing something or rather
uh he right he's an editor for colette
and uh
oh he writes for the national post so
this so he already doesn't like this guy
because he's a republican right
so now he's going and he's [ __ ]
ripping people for
you as long as you're right-wing because
seth rogen is that level right
seth rogen is is is one of those like if
you're right when you're a nazi guy like
that's how he is now that's what he's
become
um so he's just trolling their accounts
for even one this wasn't a political
post
no he wasn't saying anything political
just like oh man look how stupid i
am look how [ __ ] dumb i am can you
believe that oh man i wrote
you know i wrote my underwear backwards
today by mistake i
[ __ ] stupid piece of [ __ ] it's not
even
funny [ __ ] [ __ ] i was just tired
this morning and yeah
no you're you were [ __ ] is what you
were it was a mistake
i was just letting people know that okay
what did you expect people to do when
you told them oh you
wanted a [ __ ] parade for being a
[ __ ]
it's just just a tweet there's an anger
there's an anger coming from him that is
so yeah it's so
weird very weird anger listen i'm an
angry guy
but if i'm looking at you and going
jesus christ dude
calm down like it's not that big a deal
this this was this is and it's like
again if it was like
one isolated incident but he seems to be
legitimately spiraling
yeah no but but this is like you know
seth
a lot of people could say the same thing
about a lot of your movies looking back
so what was the joke that you smoked
weed
oh yeah dude i smoke weed hey you know
what the joke was there's a bunch of
different names for weed did you know
that
what did you expect people to say seth
oh wow maui wowie that's a weed that
i've got high with once
see my seth is the king of
jokes that are ju that aren't jokes by
the way you were never the funniest
guy in any one of your movies no you're
right that's a good point especially
like you said if jonah hill was in it
everyone everyone in the 40-year-old
virgin was funnier than you
um james franco was funnier than you in
pineapple express dude he blew him out
of the water um
like you're never the guy gary cole was
funnier than him in [ __ ] pineapple
i'm trying to think can you danny
mcbride was funnier than him
i'm trying to be objective and think of
a time when seth rogen was the funniest
guy in a movie
um he wasn't
he wasn't the funniest guy in funny
people um
his scene did make me laughing super bad
yeah i know it was
shutting the police radio off that was
funny but that even that was
but he wasn't the funniest person in the
movie no not even jonah hill was the
last guy in the movie so
yeah i i can't think of like
like if i were a producer type i would
be looking at seth rogen and thinking
why do i need you like i don't need you
i i just i just need everyone else from
oh that's a really great
really good point paul rudd was the
funniest guy knocked up
he was paul rudd was funnier than seth
rogen wasn't knocked up oh i was
thinking 40 year old version
no he wasn't no nothing else it knocked
up though yes yeah no
there was like three people funnier than
him in 40 year old virgin yeah
three or four the black guy was funny
yeah he was um i i don't
i don't get this this is a very like why
is he lashing out so hard because he's
angry royce
because he just won the election and
because he said wait no you're right
none of this makes any sense being angry
being angry weed guy look here you go
seth rogan
let's not focus on the fact that ted
cruz doesn't understand movies and focus
more on the fact that
he inspired a deadly insurrection
perpetrating lies about mass victims
the [ __ ]
uh seth rogen i damned you by buying one
of your vases but you never responded
uh thanks but i'm currently not selling
them
so he makes faces of smoke weed is this
what he does
yeah dude he's cool uh the older i get
them i find myself randomly thinking
about what uniquely powerful and
spectacular talent chris farley had
yeah don't don't you don't you [ __ ]
dare even talk about chris farley and
also
what are you doing in your [ __ ] 40s
yeah
the 50s or whatever sitting in front of
40s sitting around
thinking about how talented chris farley
was is that what you're doing
because like i occasionally will watch a
clip and go yeah he was a good guy you
do you really sit around high all day
and go man
chris farley dude imagine taking your
political advice from this [ __ ]
because he's a [ __ ] you know
listening to him uh somebody amy allen i
hope whatever is making your last shot
like this gets better seth
i'm just living with guts and confidence
he's miserable
something's wrong like there's something
going on with him right because he's
myself
i'll be honest with you and i'm not
encouraging this kind of thing i'm just
saying
as as as as an event to be observed if
seth rogen
it would be hilarious i would laugh
hysterically if seth roach
the the [ __ ] he's so angry all it is
all that
look at him i do everything stone
ma imagine being look man i don't give a
[ __ ] if you smoke weed like smoke weed
man [ __ ]
fine with me i don't [ __ ] care i
don't care if you drink dude i don't
care do coke i don't care what the [ __ ]
you do
but people that make their entire
personality about their vices
are the worst [ __ ] pieces he's too
old and famous to be
like bro [ __ ] weed dude like he's way
too old for that
yeah daniel tosh should have a good joke
once about legos i hope they legalize
marijuana
that way everyone [ __ ] stops talking
about it [ __ ] you're a grown-up do
cocaine like an adult
yeah and it's true well unfortunately we
didn't get our way because
these people don't stay still don't stop
it's legal and they don't shut the [ __ ]
up i think that it's this
cool thing that they're gonna break out
at a party yeah i got some weed
you know you can go up the street and
buy something
yeah cool not that impressed yeah it's
super easy to get weed
it's not difficult it was super easy to
get weed when it was illegal yeah it was
it may have been easier it may have been
easier to get weed when it was
cheaper yeah